[Music]
guys at this point what can you really
say about a player like zai woo he is
the king of clutches Brown continues I
knew has to shine through and a woman
too he's got the he's a man of many
words what is it like being in front of
this amazing crowd he also happens to be
the recipient of the most MVP awards in
2019 and the score eSports phenom award
2019 in other words he's pretty good
enough that picking and ranking 10 of
his best plays was legitimately
difficult but we did it anyway you're
welcome
starting this off is a sick little play
that only a mechanical God could pull
off I'm talking about the times I we
made Mirage his playground and aced the
members of a Gio in a matter of seconds
there were some legendary names in the
French CS seen on the server that day
but honestly who needs teammates when
you can do this winning out the
underpass control capo with the head for
looking off as I lose either trades it
and turns on for the Tek and maybe my
doubts may be completely unwarranted as
I will drop down spots Sparrow and deals
with him on the PHR skill
another age defined in this series this
will be the second one purrs I will base
time potentially against the man he's
gonna find it
two aces and two maps for the young star
of vitality and I think I'm actually
been convinced right there
coming in at number nine is a one before
clutch against none other than the
greatest team in cs:go history this time
at dreamhack Masters Malmo 2019 with the
bomb ticking away on vertigo zaboo was
left in a very familiar position
luckily the French prodigy was up to the
task taking down four members of a
stralla
with enough time to defuse the bomb and
the USP one tap for the final kill Oh
c'est magnifique who's gonna have a
fighting retreat but he's been worried
about the flight he knows that asteroids
has been working this maps so well
there's one shot Vegas not gonna be able
to punish him good follow-up from Zee
whoo but they're still searching and
he's got another that's three kills on
the right he can go for this he can go
for this old model I don't think he's
gonna win it Oh Ellis over tendons Iroh
has pulled something out of nowhere it's
so ridiculous especially the way that he
finishes it yeah one tap just the wee
little one time that one time at the
grand finals of ESL one cologne 2019
zero and vitality came face to face with
the then darlings of counter-strike an
ace powerhouse team liquid after tl
brutalized vitality in map one it was I
whoo-hoo once again a stepped-up put his
team on his back and closed out map two
in overtime with this one b3 clutch and
I were to get the ball back again we
said double overtime isn't out a
possibility is an unbelievable
but it might be was I who finally and
exhaust like that is he stepped back
into the door anyone plants there's no
rush slow it down as now
and hey while vitality didn't end up
winning the tournament zai was
phenomenal performance alone earned him
his third hltv MVP award of the year
number seven is an ace clutch from the
young French god this time against forza
in the mountain dew league from may 2019
40 seconds into the round zai who finds
himself alone with the bomb in hand and
miles away from a site now if there's
any player in the world right now
who's gonna pull this off you better
believe it's gonna be zai world 32 now
to his names I ruin the one versus five
and AWP in his hands and see what he's
able to do is it sports up ahead yeah
thanks to power eliminated that's the
first of what could be many more there's
a man who wears a cape on a server it
gotta be signed with a body shot coming
down to Alameda that's the second and
he's starting to build up the pressure
for force pop is the magic stick you
wanna see the fern Frank found and he's
hungry for more he seems to have
somewhat of a realization what's about
to happen
as Jerry comes in and sneaks very slowly
to get closer and closer to the a sight
both seems to be frozen in staying there
and waiting patiently as now it is only
a move from xyu to turn things around to
smoke has land its Howard CT face crack
is gonna approach back over toilets xyu
has the read he has the understanding
and he has the interest another and is
this man cannot stop getting them down
one by one by one it's a final frack he
needs together and it's Jerry take it
out as well site will Europe East your
maniac and you're the personal Grim
Reaper of vitality who's humiliating
them all the truly sickening thing about
this play is just how easy he makes it
all look taking the number six spot on
our list is another of the many moments
at ESL one cologne 2019 in which is I
will earn the moniker of prodigy with
the clock ticking away in a 1v3 clutch
against one of anaise best rosters
sang-woo lined up a ridiculous
collateral to stop Energy's initial
attempt at a plant retreating back to
spawn to let time run out like any smart
player would desire thought he done
enough but even a heroic last-second Bob
plant by Taric wasn't enough to deny the
God of French CS good double kill for
him and now it's all on sidewall here 14
seconds left oh oh no the pompon it
might be right in front and now we just
need to wait they can't find the pump
anymore in the last possible second and
side was back for more looking for him
already with the triple just needs one
more clicker less common tearing is
hiding behind tetra side windows who's
got two back kills winning it for
mortality you never seen anything like
him what a ridiculous performance coming
in at the halfway point is the time the
desire really started putting the csgo
world on notice with some fans calling
him beef French is simple what did he do
to earn that name for himself
oh just single-handedly ace hell raisers
with the scout against head armor Jesus
sorry we were waiting come with the
Scout at the edge there's the kill on
two Hulbert advantage picked up in
vitality would love to get a little bit
more here and sideways got himself a
triple kill with a scout quad from
Skyward and that's in two or three v1
and cyborgs is incredible stuff from
zero that's another is that we've seen
today from zai would incredible stuff on
the scout hellraisers walked right into
that one and the yarn French Super Start
knocks them all over at number four on
our list is yet another disgusting ace
clutch from our favorite Frenchman this
time on one of CS goes biggest stages
the starladder major after failing to
execute the classic rush b matchmaking
strat on dust2
the french prodigy turns what was an
inevitable round loss for vitality into
some good old Zulu magic
this would be such a historic comeback
Russia Pete it's a classic kickert
fighting they never stood a chance
Pharmacy win the fight piece out in the
open chest out fighting every single one
and somehow he comes out way on top side
whenever trying to fight his way back
and he's gonna have to get the ACE to
try and shut this round down and bring
his team maybe finally back into the
game a little bit he's got the right
idea but a Trent
again is such a smart player he's been
playing forever and he's sneaking up
behind side who still can't get the kill
and now Dungey ready and waiting so he's
just tapping away at the door he won the
fight is he gonna be able to get it
still alive and only in 56 health that's
not a lot against that USB he takes the
bomb a single time he's got
[Applause]
that is such a short reign at number
three we have xyu absolutely victimizing
energy for the second time on this list
this time during the semi-finals of ECS
season seven in London with the North
Americans swarming the a bomb site on
overpass young met to single-handedly
shuts down Energy's push from outside of
bathrooms in a play that makes one of
counterstrikes top teams look like a
silver matchmaking squad to use that
opportunity to make their way all the
way towards the a-site circus so away
hit it off cut it hit this short he was
ready for it as I root will take him
down it's back to the forum for one long
but said 30 seconds remaining as I was
in one of the most overlooked positions
in cs:go absolutely unbelievable and he
just puts the whole taking the runner-up
spot on our list is a series ending play
that not only left viewers at home in
awe but that casters themselves with
vitality on match point against ends at
CS summit for Z we took matters into his
own hands with the play up banana so
aggressive so balls to the wall
he would make simple blush massively on
their tee shot as well they're
anticipating banana first he's had
enough he's gonna keep going through it
he doesn't really care
couldn't make it up that's it let's put
a fork in it Jason it's done coming in
at number one on our list is a play from
ESL one cologne 2019 that typifies what
it means to be a phenom what it means to
be a prodigy and what it means to be
zero balanced on a Razors Edge this
sublime clutch is a mix of aggression
cerebral play and pure raw skill plays
like this is why we love counter-strike
apex will sit back towards the point can
also check for the ribbon on a single
kill coming in all that steps are
porradasa brawl and as I will eventually
drop him on the floor but it has to be
the one before clutch from this I would
need comes him barely enough health to
survive here on brawler both sigh he
wants to kill there's the headshot pull
the fact your bird's-eye we've got the
triple cribs is the last man standing
and there's time for the T fuse so ever
wants to smoke the palm if you're crazy
stirred and cyber wins it that is
unbelievable from the young Frenchman a
team vitality will get a 16th this man
always steps up when vitality need him
the most towards those key rounds lysis
ah well that's it for the top tens I
will plays at least so far but I think
you guys agree the way this kid is going
we could be here a year from now with an
entirely new list okay Collins
predictions for 2020 csgo
faze clan win every event both majors
become the greatest dynasty in the
history of csgo
even greater than a stralla somehow in
one year phase up we back babe
yeah
[Music]